you know me I'll be fine I'll be back as
soon as I find Chris why is everyone
thinking we get in trouble
don't shoot get down
the hell is going on I don't know
hopefully they'll have some answers at
the police station wait you're a cop
yeah Leon Kennedy you are Claire
you're Redfield
[Applause]
Claire Claire you okay right how about
you can't stay here it's not safe oh
yeah dude it's America everyone has guns
I forget this
okay where do we how did you get out
what so I don't actually get to play
from that part but I wanted to how the
hell did you get here from the burning
ass car like what what happened Leon I'm
sure you beat me here
Wow your ward here excuse me well no
that's cheating
fine but I'm a little bit annoyed of
that like I wanted to play from the
burning car I wanna know how she got
here it's this exact location or
whatever dead people in the ground
so we came in at different entrance
though which is interesting
zombi
they come in here no they want to look
around I don't think I can get in there
anyway
ah this is the helicopter bit already
okay fair enough Oh what's this Oh a
blue herb dad that's just what I need
you know that's so useful on its own
okay do I have I don't have a secondary
God dead things dead there's this thing
just wearing me yeah Claire hold on I'll
be right there okay
Claire it's so nice to see you how are
you doing that helicopter just one piece
I'm guessing you know oh yeah this
remember they like all could be flat
even though fortunately they really
should not be but how are you doing you
know just surviving that's good
any luck with your brother this is a wig
because we had played so much of Liam on
this boy's home we just are sure we'll
find him
damnit didn't like that made me choke
what that means to me that was gonna
happen did it sound ever time
where I think you should go don't worry
about me Leon you take care of your
stuff
you need to go now
let's get through this both of us
now why I've already seen your future
Claire you survived I'm not quite sure
no sorry
that's waitest okay well that's a good
start isn't it
Aniki hmm should we get ourselves some
new guns Leon how hey cyber games you
knees over now I finished a completed
completed University I mean I'm in the
real world I got myself a real job hug a
muffin puff surviving is reproducing oh
yeah grab one of these 15 shot crusty
customized a hostile increased accuracy
and ease of use we're just catching one
drawing I guess this one's good
okay now I have a lot of guns but not
much Alan
so now
where am I going am I supposed to go
back this way
was there another door in there must be
I surely can't have to go all the way
back there again
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
unless the the helicopter explosion
changed the scenery somehow they opened
up something that wasn't open before
yeah they must have done
you follow me all the way here
[Music]
[Music]
bad one so you're telling me all this
time that Leon was in there running
around which I spent a lot time in there
she was in there too and we didn't just
bump into each other
how Jesus I don't know I don't have any
room for things
[Music]
Oh scheisse
he's kidding me
confuse all over again planks of wood
gladly take some honor though
huh what just too many bride
are you dad oh you actually are okay
right looking for a safe point oh I call
me bud
either way
[Music]
don't really want to use it right now
though I think I got one will help me
keep that no use it
they open this locker where would the
fuse be if I were o in the office yes
since the logical and I think there's a
zombie in wearing shoes he's still not
dead I know he's not dead okay
yeah Oh can't carry it bulls more fine
I'll just use em I don't what do you
want to use that
wait it's not fuse I can take out no cuz
then that door closed
savor okay
oh yeah the cool save room with the hat
oh my Leon Said's anyone hey twitch
viewers don't why I can see you guys too
oh my god and you guys are so bright
wasn't I just got the stupid key sorry
don't oh oh we'll be doing that a lot
I put that in there for now because I'm
just looking around
so something special ammo for this one
that I just never found
thanks for the followed DZ Womble hey ed
you ok thanks for watching Alexander
what do you say
are you just said to go to go oh cool ok
[Music]
we'll need the cutters
maybe thanks for the follow as as this
error
apparently the picture looks better on
twitch guys so if you're having problems
on YouTube just head over to twitch job
calm calm dot TV / yeah Gannon X this is
my problem last time I just save all the
time I didn't think about it then I
forget that it actually does make some
differences in the end of the game how
much you saved I feel like I should go
back now that I've got the fuse but
definitely easier by
apparently the stream is delayed on
YouTube
[Music]
garnish sneak so this zombie does not
notice me memory around him whoa
and you hi sir did it to doom around you
oh no you know I'm here but it's okay
because I'm gone right
anybody here Shh wait where's the
typewriter
there should be a typewriter here this
is Oh guys he's here head he's not part
of the rescue squad you're very
observant are you okay
where do we go what do we oh hi nah-ah
nah-ah I missed you okay this one now
cuz you picked up that piece of paper
oh we don't need to do it oh we do
you don't she picked up the other part
of it parking way out
Oh actually I don't know it's all cause
we've only got really the unicorn one
kind of so we don't know unless Leon has
done this for us I think he has
hopefully but it looks like I might
still have to get one more Oh seriously
you both come different stats do this to
me I'm just gonna guess that the only Oh
wait you've done up ah here we go ah
here oh just this is the page that I
found ripped out yeah
okay so I'm guessing hopefully my own
custom 1-9
let's we're going to be careful because
mr. X is around here somewhere oh and so
too are the Lincoln
love it I've had any bet so we're not
running okay guys we're not we're not
doing that did I pick up this blank
Schneider hey you look on song cap when
we need you we are
hey Jacob mixing red gun powder makes
ammo for first of over nice breaking a
gun powder I don't have anything to mix
it with though I've got the white gun
powder so I wonder what
[Music]
[Music]
what what is that noise huh wanna go
we're all seven yeah oh oh that's more I
know that I can see it shouldn't really
run around it attracts mr. axe
well we gonna see
hey you remember this dude he's doing
that when Leon Sauron first time -
you've really liked that vending machine
okay also I should not be shooting
zombies like that I just realized okay
because that also attracts mystery you
know I like to live on the edge right I
really don't don't copy on that I really
don't we are doing everything again guys
for doing everything again
right white plus rag is acid grenades
for the launcher and to whites are for
the SMG right thanks for the
subscription blue summers 101 he really
wants a Snickers bar I mean yeah penis
is great thanks for subscribing right
it's 2 & 3 on anything that's not I can
get that when I was 6 I wonder if it's
just gonna be the same there cuz that's
just a roll of film right and didn't we
get that when we were early on that's
why we did I wonder if that's just gonna
be exactly the same thing wasting my
time commemoration
[Music]
1:09
why is weird
is there a zombie in the air
[Music]
Jesus always just come in to row eight
eight I knocked your hat off sir
oh good
and he was just out here - so now he's
busy in there okay yeah so right now
you're part of ah here we go gonna put a
high-grade gunpowder asset Brown
submachine sorry
no it's handguns anyway our hydrants
anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you follow me from the other room stop
stressing me out
stop it okay it's open Leon's desk
please
hey Tom hey Tom people mayfair your name
what difficulty is this
there's only normal difficulty I didn't
go on aim assisted no that's the main
thing
[Music]
they don't die it's so annoying he's
gonna get back up okay so I remember I
have to put in all of their names right
before this stupid-ass dude gets like
out Phillips right so where's their
names and this n E Ned right a needy Ned
Ned and this one is oh there's a little
things that kill so much and are to you
sir and no okay no okay no I know
I stink I thought it was NR
[Music]
I know oh no oh no indeed thank you all
the keyboard keys are in different
places and the combinations of the same
combinations are the same you kidding me
I wish I freaking remembered them Thanks
I could I could just like get up my O's
n R don''t so just get up my old
playthrough just go through that what
gun is not to be used on
it's not this one where are you
I could hear you aha I can't read you of
my knife and I don't want to waste any
more maybe she's signed to you she knew
she didn't actually do that nine laughs
15 bite seven left you think okay so
let's try that
nine now 15 right 7 left 9 15 7 I love
to do 9 left
9:15 my 1:15 thanks younger my friend
you're so awesome you saying hey listen
listen listen to what little listen
listen to what 15 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
thank you so much
I got my hitch pass my hitch pouch might
yes my hitch pouch right there Marcin
song because I know I said the rest of
you it's a mole some Lance um nothing
III knew I would butcher it anyway
where's the light switch right let's use
this yeah it is the same boring
we got red hair though it's quite nice
contains evidence
do not leave out okay so can we actually
use these some right edges yes sweet
this is good um do I need everything
here oh we don't need these anymore
nice yeah I'll keep the red hubs
use only knife do you guys remember when
we were playing Resident Evil 7 and I
tried to kill them oh what's his name
you the man that like never dies the
real freaking scary ass one I tried to
kill him with a knife because I forgot
to pick up the chainsaw do you remember
that I thought we did like pretty well
we kind of lasted a long time I was
ready strike okay that and that would
make submachine ammo but I don't need
submachine ammo I'm gonna keep it anyway
just so I can make some more ammo when I
come across some more gunpowder
zabi why are you wet I got some planks
[Music]
hi there you are I'm going up here see
ya nice day because here she is I'm
gonna pull hair
excuse me why are you making that noise
though oh please the Clank we need
thank you so much
jackoff what did you say what item you
put in combines with the beginning
revolver that item you put in combines
with the beginning revolver I destroyed
the combining day and it said it
wouldn't I'll try winning it back
[Music]
I know they're still in here but I'm
just yeah I think that handle is what we
need
[Music]
[Music]
unless you my name is falesha gun oh
this one right okay
that's the esse now about 3d guns do
even Obama for that
[Music]
that's where I'll combine these and then
I'll have some more space
20 spy residue boys just mainly trying
to sort out your inventory I'm not doing
too badly there look at that
should we use one caution mmm
probably [ __ ] they're all zombies like
right outside and I don't hear oh hey
I knew you're in here okay I'll give you
something you see you're okay you're
fine now what now what do we do okay
look your room look a hallway yeah yeah
I reckon he's back
[Music]
please don't get up because I really
don't want to have to fight zombies on
the kids again because that was not a
fun combination probably gonna have to
come back to get the rest of this oh
look it's from Leon guys Claire I hope
you get this this place is crawling with
monsters and your brother's not here
just get out of here as soon as you can
already hope you sleep you've got to be
in there at the same time she got in
straight after you basically
I don't need this battery what do I do
where's the nearest okay there's no luck
here though that's the kid thing at
least thank goodness there's a liquor
and I really should have killed up these
zombies but now they don't get me but
I'm already being
[Music]
nobody is no point in having three guns
there we go right so which one should we
quote well I guess we'll have to which
one is the worst one yes
you don't want I'll put my fresh name as
well actually and then I will save again
okay one sec guys
cool costumes kind of afraid just the
original but you know that's that's cool
- yes yeah sure why not let's play him
weird outfits cool she oh she does look
pretty cool anyway I'll be right back
you
you
meeting a meeting day yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
opposite narrator Jasmine pees really
fast she loves this scared I don't even
anything I just here
[Music]
hey I see your heart unicorn sore but
don't spam the chat
[Music]
[Music]
am I mistaken no no no no although
there's no freaking save in here which
it's a high green hair how do past your
last time right now mr. X is gonna be
drawn to that I need to get back
upstairs
well it's okay just hunt the wall you
can't be stupid blind can see you mr.
axe
mr. bloody axe
[Music]
I thought he was like coming from the
top floor in tonight
[Music]
this first set smoke you want to drink a
p.m. I can see that um yes I need to go
back to the top floor
get the battery well not that not even
the top floor just you have that floor
get the battery and then I can go then I
can go to the top floor
he's right here can always gone up
upstairs upstairs okay well that's good
I can work with this
yeah thank you so me for like a moment
and then you lost me again I'm hoping
[Music]
I'm just walking him I really don't want
to attract your attention I know he's
around us somewhere I know there's more
stuff in that vibe really don't want to
bounce tell myself dude you do just
don't know what to do with myself doo
doo doo doo does anyone get that all
right there's a view some of this we
have more ways around someplace
something here the backs get old
resonance a present your seven box oh
cool
so that's how we find out about the line
one this time interesting interesting
with a little mix-up there okay so you
know it's kind of missing stuff but we
can kind of see here I guess a little
bit so two people holding hands person
with scales and a cat what is that
that's of course
Oh
[Music]
sometimes I feel like I need to go save
wait you plan on reloading but at the
same time oh this is bad come on girl
on that ladder get your ass moving
so just trying to do the freakin puzzles
though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know keep going down
do not give my consent for this yes your
leg fell off her heart attack kind of
stroke okay so we got this which is
great oh look at least we can do this
now
cool so ground
[Music]
we do have fresh side sprays yes that's
good
no she's a been excused to be a vas I
have a blue and a red hair up so if I
get another green then that that'd be
pretty dandy okay
where am I trying to go to you now oh
yeah so I can go and get the other
medallion all the way up there and I can
put this one into and we can go and get
the line one now so we're kind of
breezing through this so I'm not really
you're kind of running through it very
very quick face I don't want to shoot
way to go
is he upstairs please don't be upset I
don't
[Music]
oh Jesus
right no time for dilly-dallying kill
the zombies
[Music]
the game is engineered to be the biggest
inconvenience to your game players who a
new hospital freakin is though like I
swear when I was Leon missed X wasn't
this much of an inconvenience but I
guess it's because he came a little
wasted through right which way should we
go then
no I don't need two bags perfectly okay
right now
yeah he stopped
I can't ready to [ __ ] tell where he
is I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm staying very
annoyed because I kind of
let's get that freaking key where was it
right
[Music]
Freddie don't enjoy this this is too
much
I think
[Music]
[Music]
I just want to get to the savoury please
don't tell me he's coming upstairs it's
like I have [ __ ] duck in the ass he
actually is
whoa dude yeah that's nice though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and you in there don't need you right
now
do I have any more still have a fresh
egg spray which is good what's the aim
of the game now oh yeah the last
battalion so we just need to get back to
the main room we can do this we can do
this we can do this oh I'm so sorry I
don't know why I say these things when I
got really like angry and like I just
like stuff comes out of my mouth nice
stuff
oh yeah yeah I know about the Hat thing
I actually did try and shoes how earlier
but I was panicking way too much I saw
his hat off when I was Leon though I
can't achieve it
yeah I'm gonna save now I'm gonna use
this in a second and attempt to get back
where's it sound like doors are opening
when they're not so weird
please listen to me I am listen to
Jackson Jack she has the summer edges
yeah but I ran out of ammo so I'm just
put it back today I was playing with
this one but I just ran out of ammo for
it so I just put it back
yeah I know my thoughts exactly
that's so fun I love
[Music]
please don't let him come from this way
please please please disease where's the
[ __ ] key
[Music]
right
we've got them but I feel like we
haven't like found enough but like
honestly this is so anxiety inducing I
don't even want to find everything it's
not only the zombies everywhere but
freakin mr. X is like
I need some fines at least get that key
so we know it's here I've just been an
idiot and obviously don't pass Oh No
you know anything now try and get past
the liquor nice don't need to keep a
swift ish pace because there's certain
someone on my trail
you know he's sniffing me out this is
not fun I don't know if I'm enjoying
this I don't know we'll see I mean I
wanna I want to like get to the
orphanage that's all I want to do I just
want to get in a new area it's kind of
annoying I'm doing the same thing it's
just harder it's not really what I enjoy
but I'll see I'll keep playing so we
just gotta get one medallion where the
hell did I pick up that key oh yeah I
remember is on top floor top top floor
okay that's cool so I've got the meeting
I've got unicorn so I just got to get
the lion now
[Music]
okay
no no no no no no no no we being quiet
so that the sex don't come find us if he
like randomly appears on this floor now
I'm gonna be so annoyed
I feel like I have a nasty surprise like
coming either from a zombie y'all from
the mr.
[Music]
[Music]
but you know mr. X is on my trail so
please don't no no nothing nothing okay
great wasting my time
lady
[Music]
let's go we got the freakin key right
safe because I'm in a better
circumstance now
[Music]
this hard when you're playing with the
player the first time scenario fee
hello friends every time
question where haven't I been that I
could possibly go anomalous to do that
the operations room what they can go in
here how yeah I think I have been oh I
have been there yeah of course I've been
there
well that's hangar mom oh that I didn't
pick up
there's a green half in the office over
this way
wish I could save
wish I could save out here oh my god
that's a first
[Music]
oh good I thought those mr. X musicals
like I um I want this let's get the USB
Hey okay so um as as we have things
which way to go
I'm gonna go in here and we're gonna get
the greenhouse I'm gonna go round
Jesus what do I have a check are you up
where is this bloody safe room how do I
get there okay I know
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah a muffin thank you so much
Jack so quest you go to settings and
change the music to the original game
soundtrack oh oh that's so nice of you
to do a super job for Jackson how do I
do this
I guess it would be here
no it's not how do I change that then
[Music]
hmm where would it be
unless there was more options and no
this is it I don't know where I'll be
she don't have I don't have a parenting
I guess I owe you $5 muffin face muffin
face yeah
I don't know i don't i don't think i
bought the deluxe edition did i I don't
know who cuz when I bought it it was
week so I was about to and then I
decided against it but then I think I
accidentally did but I'm like not too
sure because I was kind of half asleep
that wasn't trying yeah I don't think I
did in the end I think I saved a little
bit of money by not should I say I
probably should save why am I here what
what is my reasoning oh that was a
Lincoln over there
her little derpy face she's like I know
how to do guns now right oh that's
that's an absolutely me I can't go down
here though time do I need a key for it
oh is it just it just lot it's just no
way it's just loves great
what doors can I open then this key of
mine okay I find a fancy fancy looking
clean
this one
wait can I get that now in the waiting
room I don't think so
surely not could i well we'll have a
look hmm good if we good there's some
more time were there
okay
it was there anything here that we've
missed is manna in the East office
over here right please restrain we still
need to get so many of you such a vital
area no
which turkeys when you coming down this
track please don't be this one I can go
in that way or I can start looking
around here
wait these racks even here don't think
so this is good this is gonna be locked
it turns a museum into a police you know
I'm done I'm out I'm Audi Rosie serious
nope
he's actually so much harder just with
not having the save in the middle there
[Music]
why am I making weird noises where am I
going
it'd be nice if I could get that
[Music]
[Music]
I don't got for you
let's wait for him to come and then go
around oh wait it's not chasing me
anymore
now we good I want to find that blue hey
there Sonny Boy I'm not a witch
you do want to waste so mr. X no I don't
he is unstoppable and I'm not wasting it
on this day okay what should we do so
we've got we've got a lot of these now
so we can take these out a little bit
more empowered which is nice store this
for now we have here hi grenade
gunpowder we have a lot this has to be
that we can do this what does this make
for acid round so nice okay
you would be nice if we could go and get
some more ammo oh there's some around
here I just gotta go up there okay cool
I think I know where that is
just like karate kick mister
[Music]
I think it's upset
it's fun huh mama oh thank you haha yes
that feels like
[Music]
screw you guys I'm going by just save
room oh hey guys
oh this feels so good wait are they
coming nothing no I think for me to a
safe room recipe was breaking the rules
okay ah no that's not creepy it is
coming
[Music]
wait this means I know what that means
and it's not good for coming
[Music]
stop messing around
Thank You future a message to you
building Jax and Jax like no they won't
come in they did them didn't they they
did though look at ya some flexing
little fake guns on the zombies and they
still walk through like they don't even
care they're what all right be right
back
you
Thanks it's your boy mantas telling me
thanks for subscribing tell them tell
them Telemachus and Telemachus Kindle
and Demi Chan and yes that was another
pee break because I have the tiniest
bladder but yeah I was saying I don't
have any ammo for this one anymore
[Music]
should keep it out anyway only they'll
keep this one anyway just cuz again
[Music]
so we could be happy in the corner of
our room
Jackson Jack I told you that an October
secrecy
you thought that you wouldn't tell I
can't afford a bathroom okay oh yeah
nice one that badge
are these tools open now
hello this is the same as before
by Lucas
I just remember doing the exact same
weight is this gonna be exactly the same
but now your tiny just go underneath
hello hey
it's okay I won't hurt you I promise you
need help your you take my hand I'm
sorry I can't understand you
you need help
why he's right behind you
[Music]
okay where's your ID I know how this
works
I've done this a few times now thank you
very much for your subscription I need
your ID to be open for this to work
buddy
open up your eyes thank you for
subscription
don't want to waste it
you're in danger if I can find a blue
I'm burning to something
bring her why you can't always get what
you want in life
[Music]
he's an angry puppy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi can you pick it up please
[Music]
this time you didn't say help me to do
how kind of load faster yes ma'am
Hey
Oh a party Oh should have used the acid
Browns ah oh well no it's over
are you sure yeah I promise everything's
fine
you just need you to lower that ladder
for me will you help me find my mom
your mom is down here I think so I hope
so
Oh No yeah no way I know where mom is
right now I'll help you
okay oh it does it for NATO hit I miss
no and some other sweet I'm gonna look
around just make sure that
absolutely everything surprise it was
gonna be hard but that was then we're
two green herbs there so I am actually
quite lucky actually really generous
usually just a bunch of blue hands when
you really don't need them
nope nope
cool yeah we got everything let's go
student grunt baby sings simulator wait
wait hold up I need to loot no not
examine
oh hello I am lucky okay shorts it won't
move yes probably this your weak ass
and you're on yeah I don't think I ever
even looks out here when I was real
oh wait
he girl
so it boy what's your mom like she's
making an important new medicine
umbrella that big pharmaceutical company
yeah my mom's always that word I don't
get to see her much well hopefully
you'll get to see her again soon
why is she in the basement of the police
department though oh yeah of course uses
a well just my mom is too busy for fun
Wow both of my parents are gone it's
just me and my brother
oh I'm Sundy don't be it means we've got
something in common in that's a good
thing right
she's cute nice okay I take it back I
was being a grumpy little moody person
before I do like this yeah like it cuz
it feels like it's definitely kind of a
totally new story now but you've even
got a green herb in our box guys okay
whatever is this one I'm ray let me
answer that's this one
and that's so much oh no okay I'm gonna
be leaving soon by the way guys I need
to have my dinner follow the little
munchkin see yeah that's just just a
warning I will be intending to stop this
soon but I'm quite enjoying it I didn't
save did I did I just say yeah I did
hear one
over there
slow down girl
Wow
this is not good is it why you leave me
to dead ends girl boy girl yeah
dammit need a key card here come up and
you're sure this is the way this is how
my mom took me last time
Shirley who's this
I've been looking everywhere for you
Cheri brave little girl the beaver house
in the middle of this mess
on the ground hands behind your head you
can't be serious
on the ground now
well that's a waste Jerry
tie her hands how you doing shut up type
okay then you tire up now or she dies
what's this all about child endangerment
for starters sherry
you were the only luster what are you
gonna do to her I'm your [ __ ]
business
[Music]
get over here
what's your name
what's your [ __ ] hand
Claire say goodbye okay absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I don't really think that's ensure
is handling wrong key card first then
that [ __ ] gets what's coming to him
would you just pick up what did you pick
up oh I got a letter from my best friend
dick Claire first of all thanks for the
letter now if you let me get one thing
off my chest
I can't believe you're really gonna do
it I can't believe you're baking all the
way to Raccoon City all by yourself just
to see your brother what the hell girl I
know Chris means a lot to you and yeah
you haven't been able to reach him for a
month and all but you're nuts you know
how many perverts and [ __ ] are out
there well we just met one example a
exhibit ain't just waiting for a young
college student to come along well it
seems like he was waiting for someone I
want younger but anyway and take
advantage of it's not safe to travel
alone but your mind's made up isn't it
fine I'll get it I get it just promise
you'll call when you get to Raccoon City
don't leave your bestest best friend
hanging okay love ya PS your brother may
be the Chris Redfield and he may have
taught you how to fight and he's a gun
like a banshee also this this this
explains why she
has a gun and she can kind of use it
this is good wouldn't know she can tease
it this is good but that doesn't make
you invincible so don't get cocky out
there okay there's a tutorial okay
[Music]
so we can't go in here
whereas before we can't do in there
right why don't the trunk is post no no
it's not keep thinking things are gonna
be quite different but it's done yeah
must be where that guy came from this is
new
attention all vacuum city heroes who's
the most feared yet respected man in
town the answer should be obvious to any
resident of our fair city that's why
it's belief Chief Brian irons the man
that scares the bejesus out of all
criminals everywhere and stand father
that loves every last one of us sinful
citizens she finds is known for his
great charity work including big
contributions to the orphanage support
for abused women that's me well no me no
me Chris Chris oh my gosh clash art
preservation animal conservation let us
know if we missed anything just when
does our great here asleep when asked
the city is my extended family I'm just
doing what I'd do for my family she
finds sad for this soft smile he is not
smile in there that bastard is the
police chief so is that gonna lead me
back upstairs
not for general use oh no I can't use
the other baby because I'm not the chief
what a corrupt system
[Music]
I remember this being not know much fun
oh cool we got the key so this is my
message mr. Raoul
mr. raccoon is not honest podium
by the way I walk slowly around dead
things on the floor cuz part of me
thinks that if I'm slow they won't wake
up and hurt me it's probably wrong
also that looking
oh they're in here right right right
[Music]
hey over here nope nope nope Oh at least
they killed the dogs for us like nine
gallopin this where we can do what we
need to need this
what the hell is up with you I wish my
shotgun
oh my god Jesus bloody how many
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for the follow
[Music]
be roaches
please don't get mad I just I wish I
could just stump on your bloody hair
I'm gonna put you back in just kiss me
don't worry
dala dala love knock i will use the key
for the car
the exact same thing I know you wake up
[Applause]
wait what you not even hold anything I
needed good good okay
ah hey
okay this is better this is the better
scenario
I'm happier with this yeah just got a
knock look in that direction but I don't
even know the dangers
[Music]
okay goodbye
[Applause]
my housemate now knows when I play resin
using and she's like
[Music]
Jesus
oh yeah it always did with a nice new
job okay
yeah crap
come on quickly run to me I guess I
could use it
yeah scurrilous use it
so God I'm gonna pick up a blue and then
it got read it again and I got another
green in my that's gonna take up two
spaces now so so gonna go one more here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I want it but okay I'll have to come
back to that
this is new this is cool this is so cool
hi poor little stuffed guys police chief
ions as thanks for your unwavering
support I have deposited a small sum
into your pal account to use as you see
fit
I hope I can count on you to maintain
surveillance over your subordinates
especially the ones who survived that
mansion get rid of them if you must know
I ran into some trouble with umbrella
headquarters
the suits want to take the fruit of my
research away oh so this ties in with
the lesser that we found in umbrella
where they were like you terminated
you're not working with us anymore they
don't why this will all blow over soon
you just keep doing what I tell you I do
you'll be alright you're up - you are -
up the your - up the security around my
lab your muscleheads are to shoot any
suspicious person on sight doesn't
matter if they kill them or even if
their umbrella employees I'm so close to
completing G and no [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] together and do your
[ __ ] job I told you I need one
skirting the sewers
don't you know how critical of a time
this is for me as for the money I can
pay you whatever once I take over but
not before why don't you get that never
forget how expendable you are and then
then we can go grab green have I make a
green yellow agreeing to a red mixture
Oh
everything in this room
so where are we
chief's office hmm I'm gonna save just
check out these other places quickly
Wow hello that
[Music]
thank you for subscribing Mustafa
okay
this is get open by the heart key that's
so weird
from your description regarding the
electronic lock on the door and the
police chief's office it sounds like
something these are placing the only
some power panel parts to fix the issue
fortunately a repairman from one of our
stories is at the station to repair the
bell in the clock tower
we sent a few spare parts with him and
he reported that he left one in the
third floor East storage room is when it
goes wrong or you need more than one
please don't hesitate to seek him out in
the clock tower okay okay obviously you
need
I'm enjoying this and the beginning the
I'm not a judge is about like yeah this
is cool
pleased with how it turned out but maybe
I'm getting tired of working these PE
things maybe turn to is one to more
challenging that was seen dear a puny
puny deer and it he came when ice like
what okay do you monetized what okay um
this specimens body is soft sweet and
white all over and it's all mine forever
this I ask you this man is strange
well
I guess I will save again and say
goodnight because what time is it it's
gotta be it's gotta be dinnertime it's
gotta be you guys yeah it's pretty gross
right there's no nice but yeah anyway
thank you very much for watching I'm not
too sure when the next one will be
because next weekend as I said I'm going
to film my music video so I'll be fun
but I'll be away all weekend so